what's going on reject nation it's Greg
outta here
and I'm the hump we are going to watch
the official trailer numero dos for
Slender Man the first show look pretty
creepy hey guys on patreon we do
full-length TV show reactions from many
issues including weekly Q&A s and music
video coverage beyond that patron the
day shout-out gonna give one today to a
man named Austin Moore Austin Moore has
this really great YouTube channel where
he is developing kind of like several
Star Wars fan made short films he has
one Lego one that's really awesome and
right now though you know YouTube can be
really tough with payments and all that
so he has a part-time job at the best
place you can get a part-time job at
McDonald's Nikki days
McDonald's wack Arnold I would love to
meet up with you at a McDonald's do you
understand that's the dream I eat pretty
healthy throughout the week these days
and my cheat day nine times out of 10 is
McDonald if you really want to be a good
patronage a cook me yes in McDonald's
Bret - for for sausage McMuffin with egg
it's delicious and extra hash brown to
go with the combo cuz you need a hash
brown per Sam I know how to deal work so
then on the ride home you get a
cheeseburger - keep going you're
digesting exactly exactly
then you smoke a little bit of you know
what YouTube's not appropriate let's
just watch the Slenderman all right I
love you Austin thanks for being here
buddy me too buddy
we'll we'll have some McDonald's
together one day in town together
[Music]
[Music]
we talked about running away check this
out he preys on sanitation when you hear
the first opening
[Music]
[Music]
people dad pg-13 that's exactly how I
want my Slenderman story and it doesn't
feel pg-13 you know it feels very gritty
and foreboding it looks like one of
those movies were you gonna watch people
just slowly deteriorate words and words
until the end I liked the first trailer
more the first trailer seemed to hone in
more on a unique tone something that was
just really haunted and demented and
creepy and eerie throughout well if I'm
looking from a studio perspective one
trailer appeals more to the filmmakers
and then this trailer appeals more for a
mainstream audiences it's a fair thing
to do but this one actually gives you
some actual scenes so I feel like this
trailer represents the movie probably a
little more accurately than the last one
I don't know it was like this really
creepy and scary horror movie girls yeah
kind of horror movie to expect from them
and I still feel like it could go either
way and I guess what both trailers have
done that is cool to me is they've
surprised me with certain flourishes or
certain kinds of moments that I just
wasn't expecting to see like there's
some surprisingly cool-looking visual
flourishes like when they are focusing
on that one girl then the camera like
turns around and the background
dissolves my yeah that looks visually
interesting in a way I wasn't expecting
but yeah this looks more like a regular
horror movie
last trailer made it look like the
majority of the film would be that way
which would mean it's rep that trailer
was representing the entirety of the
film and then this trailer made me go oh
those cool things are gonna come
sporadically these things are gonna come
very intermittently or cool horror movie
effects stuff yeah I mean this seems
like the kind of movie that would want
to do that especially looking at this
trailer like periodically we're gonna
throw in something creepy because the
Slender Man has to have like a subtle
onset before things just go wild I feel
like I can get on board with this film
if like okay maybe the first half
our 240 minutes is like whatever generic
horror film contained and then it goes
like bad [ __ ] in the last half yeah and
I would be like oh that was a cool film
but if it's just generic horror movie
throughout and with like intermitting
cool stuff yeah yeah I really hope not I
feel like this Letterman has enough to
its source material into the various
iterations over time to make it so that
this wouldn't just become a rote horror
movie and it seems like and I pointed
this out of the first trailer reaction
that they're borrowing from every
generation of the Slender Man yeah it
could become really unsettling but it
could also yet not do that I've got like
a 50/50 with this movie I'm hoping
they'll do it but I'm not really sure
the thing that's new to me and this
trailer is the whole rules part but it's
like there will be three bells and you
got to close your eyes on the second
exactly like that's very much to me out
of creepypasta stuff like there are
other creepy pastas and there are other
like spooky games you can play with
right like that
Slenderman as far as I know never really
had that but you know I get how they
brought it in unless that's from the
game or something I know I don't know I
guess I like this trailer alright I mean
I I hope it's cool I like the ensemble
so yeah as you guys liked this trailer
did you prefer it remember the first one
your opinion you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click this
notification bail because subscribe
buttons are broken and check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A music video coverage love to
have you become a patron ejected a